يبدو انه مالك تويتر الى الماسك لازال
مستمر في محاولات ايجاد حل لاكبر مشكله
بتواجه تويتر وهي الضعف الايرادات فصحيح
انه تويتر من الصدخمه ولكن ارادتها مقارنه
بغيرها من المنصات ضعيفه وماسك من اول ما
استلم تويتر وهو بيصدر قرارات وسياسات
جديده بتساهم نوعا ما في رفع ارادات
الشركه كلها تحت عنوان ادفع وهذه التقارير
وهذه المره تحديدا التقارير التي تتكلم عن
طريق مبتكره وجديده على تويتر فقارير قالت
انه تويتر بتدرس طرح اسماء مستخدمين للبيع
في مزادات اون لاين المقصود هنا يعني
اليوزر نيمز والهندز والاسماء اللي راح
تطلع او تطرح للبيع هي اسماء الحسابات غير
نشطه من سنوات واصحابها ما بيستخدموها ولا
حتى سجلوا دخول من سنين يعني بدل ما تفضل
كده اسماء المستخدم محجوزه لهم على الفاضي
وكثير منها حتى يوزرات مميزه جدا فخلاص
تويتر يرجع يطلق صراحه وتنبع وكان الى
الناس كمان لما احنا من فتره للموضوع
ونشرته ده قال فيها انه تويتر راح يحرر
مليار ونص حساب في سبيل اتاحه اسماء
للمستخدمين الجدد واكد انه الحسابات اللي
راح تحذف فيه حسابات غير نشطه فلا بتغرد
ولا سجلت دخول على المنصه اصلا من سنوات
وطبعا في نقطه لازم نذكر فيها وهي انه
شركه تويتر بتمنع اصلا بيع وشراء اسم
المستخدم لكن هذا الشيء كان طبعا بيصير في
السوق السوداء ولكن يبدو انه السياسي
الجديده تغيرت للشركه والموضوع راح يصير
قانوني ورسمي وانا ماسك ما راح يترك
بطريقه يحاول من خلال زياده الشركه وخاصه
مع المشاكل اللي واجهها من وقت اشترت
تويتر واللي من بينها توقف الاعلانات على
المنصه ومغادره كثيرين من بعض فرد رسوم
على
الثقه طيب
وبمناسبه الحديث عن تويتر وماسك الايرادات
والفلوس والمزادات ففي خبر ثاني عن ماسك
مهم جدا اليوم
اللي معودنا على المفاجات والابتكارات
والفكره المستقبلي والارقام القياسيه
وتصدر القوائم بمختلف انواعها حقق رقم
قياسي جديد وهذه المره كمان دخل في موسوعه
جنس بس للاسف لكن بالخساره فموسوعه
الارقام القياسيه سجلت ماسك اكثر شخص
بيخسر ثروه شخصيه في التاريخ
ماسك منه نوفمبر 20 21 خسر
182 مليار دولار بينهم مصادر ثانيه بتقول
انه الرقم اكبر من كده وبيصل الى 200
مليار في كل الاحوال يعني فك هو رغم انه
تحديد يعني بالضبط خسر كم صعب لكن كسروا
الرقم
كسر الرقم القياسي وكسر مراحل في الرقم
القياس السابق لاكبر خساره شخصيه كان رجل
اعمال الياباني ما سيشون واللي سنه فين
خسرت 58 مليار دولار اما ماسك فخسر 200
مليار تقريبا مثل ما قلنا ثروه نزلت من
320 مليار في 20 21 ل 138 مليار في يناير
20 23 الخساره طبعا سببها الاساسي شراء
اولى توتر وكل الجدل اللي صار وكمان
انخفاض في اسهم شركه تسلا وبعد كل هذه
الخساره ماسك لسه من اغنى اغنياء العالم
طبعا لكن خسر المركز الاول ونزل للثاني
وترك منصب الاغنام لبرنارد ارنو صاحب
مجموعه قلبي ثروته الحاليه هي 190 مليار
دولار